- Smart Summon and soon Autopark
takes on the full beautiful
mess of parking lots
and their human-to-human
non-verbal communication.
I think it has actually the potential
to have a profound impact in changing
how our civilization
looks at AI and robotics,
because this is the
first time human beings,
people that don't own a Tesla,
may have never seen a Tesla
or heard about a Tesla, get
to watch hundreds of thousands
of cars without a driver.
Do you see it this way
almost like an education tool
for the world about AI?
Do you feel the burden of
that, the excitement of that,
or do you just think it's
a smart parking feature?
- I do think you are getting
at something important
which is most people have
never really seen a robot,
and what is the car that is autonomous?
It's a four-wheeled robot.
- Yeah, it communicates
a certain sort of message
with everything from
safety to the possibility
of what AI could bring, to
its current limitations,
its current challenges, what's possible;
do you feel the burden of that
almost like a communicator,
educator to the world about AI.
- We're just really trying
to make people's lives easier
with autonomy. But now
that you mention it,
I think it will be an eye
opener to people about robotics.
Because most people
have never seen a robot
and there are hundreds
of thousands of Teslas,
won't be long before
there's a million of them
that have autonomous capability
and that drive without a person in it.
And you can see the kind of evolution
of the car's personality and thinking
with each iteration of Autopilot.
You can see it's uncertain about this,
but now it's more certain.
Now it's moving in a
slightly different way.
I tell immediately if a
car is on Tesla Autopilot
because it's got just
little nuances of movement.
It just moves in a slightly different way.
Cars on Tesla Autopilot,
for example, on the highway
are far more precise about
being in the center of the lane
than a person.
If you drive down the highway
and look at where cars are,
the human-driven cars,
are within their lane.
They're like bumper cars.
They're moving all over the place.
The car on Autopilot, dead center.